so if you watch my review for the
conjuring 2 you know that I really love
that movie I loved it I thought it was
great it was one of the best horror
films I've seen in a long time and I
mentioned that I had an experience at
the screening for it that just it just
got to this point where I couldn't
really not talk about it I made a video
a couple years back called a rant on
annoying film goers and it did pretty
well it was actually on the news and
that was very surprising very humbling
for me but it told me that there were
thousands and thousands hundreds of
thousands really of people out there who
felt just like I did
annoyed with how disrespectful people
have gotten in movie theaters today see
Hollywood has this viewpoint right now
and I can I can tell they're afraid
they're afraid because of things like
VOD or the the screening room that whole
thing where that guy came out and said
you know for 50 bucks or whatever you
can see any film you want to at home and
it's in theaters and there's a lot of
filmmakers that are on his side and a
lot of filmmakers that aren't on his
side Hollywood's afraid they're afraid
that people are going to stop going to
the movie theaters they think it has to
do with online torrenting piracy the
screening room or perhaps VOD or the
fact that people just are lazy and want
to stay at home they have all these
different things they want to say
certain theater chains are even looking
for ways they can have entire
auditoriums designated for people who
just want to be on their cell phones the
entire time you gotta be kidding me I
love movies I live and breathe movies
I've examined movies my entire life I
love them they're my favorite form of
art they can touch me on a very deep
level
I like making films I've been making
short films ever since I was a kid and I
love it I love movies I love films so
naturally I love going to the movie
theaters it's a great place the movie
theater is incredible when the lights go
down and that movie starts no matter
what movie it's gonna be I'm pumped
there's something magical about it
whoever you're with whether it's the
person you
dating your husband your wife your
boyfriend your girlfriend your family
your mother your father or just your
friends or maybe you're by yourself
going to the movie theater is special
that's what I would have said about 10
years ago today in 2016 it's pretty much
a disaster to fully understand my point
here I need to explain to you how the
screening process works in Ohio where I
live see in LA when you go to a movie
screening it's basically always
virtually entirely filled with press and
there's so many press in LA that they
can fill a theater with nothing but
press that's awesome whenever I go to a
screening when I visit LA it's always
fantastic people are quiet people are
respectful because almost everyone there
is press in Ohio it's a little bit
different there aren't as many press out
here so when I travel to Cleveland to go
to a press screening of a film it's not
always press only very rarely do I get
to go to a press only screening which
trust me that is heaven that is the
definition of heaven on earth to myself
there are like five people there myself
included and everyone is dead silent
I saw x-men apocalypse at a press only
screening it was glorious this is
amazing I feel incredible yes yes yes
yes I can win I feel great I can't do
this but most of the time in Ohio a
press screening is actually a few rows
designated for press and then a bunch of
other tickets are then given away on say
the radio or an online contest of some
kind and people who aren't pressed then
fill up the theater and when I say fill
up the theater I mean they fill up the
theater because it's a screening
agency's job to market this film before
its release they want word-of-mouth they
want people to tweet they want people to
hashtag that thing all over the place so
this gun can get some promotion so it's
their job to get as many people into
this theater as possible to help promote
the film they're trying to promote for
their studio whatever that studio may be
with this video I'm not naming names
I'm not calling out studios I'm not
calling out theater chains because I
don't want to step on anyone's toes I'm
a nice guy
I am a nice guy I'm the guy who goes to
theater and tries to respect everyone
around them one of the reasons I'm
filming this video in my new house is
because I know I'm about to get really
fucking loud at my old condo I have
neighbors on either side of me and I
don't want to disturb them
that's called being respectful of the
people around you something that people
in movie theaters nowadays seemingly
have forgotten completely about so in
Ohio when I go to a film screening there
are a few people there as press and the
rest are just a whole bunch of people
who are like oh wow a free movie of
course I'll go what movie is it I don't
care it's free yay free free free that
means I can do whatever I want and put
my feet right next to your face I can be
as loud as I want I can annoy you the
entire time
I can audibly speak to the screen the
entire time and completely ruin your
experience and that's what happened to
me tonight at the conjuring 2 screening
I sat down immediately I knew it was
going to be a problem a person sat
behind me now at this screening they
actually did show a few previews which
is rare
usually at screenings they don't show
any previews but these previews were
attached to the same studio that made
the conjuring 2 and so those previews
were there to help market those movies
as soon as the preview for lights-out
came on a movie I'm really anticipating
the person behind me felt the need to
continuously say oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh god um oh god oh my
god oh oh oh my god no no oh god no I
can't do this no oh my god now I know
what you're thinking you're thinking oh
it's just the previous crisps it doesn't
matter you're just complaining you're
complainer you don't even have to pay to
be there and you're complaining
no let me tell you about screenings
where I live I don't live near Cleveland
I live outside of Cleveland it takes me
about 40 to 45 minutes sometimes an hour
to get to where they have these
screenings now I live a half a mile away
from a theater right now half a mile
takes me like a minute to get to my
neighborhood dater if I want to go to
see a movie there say on Thursday night
at 7:00 p.m. that's awesome I pay like
10 bucks there's barely anybody there
and I go home and I do my review but
let's say in the case of the conjuring 2
I get a very early screening I can get
an early review out to you guys on top
of that I really like the first
conjuring I want to see conjuring 2 I'm
excited to see conjuring 2 I like James
Wan I think he's the best horror
director working today
so naturally I'm excited to go to the
screening but it takes me 45 minutes to
get there and 45 minutes to get back
guess how much money that equates to in
regards to gas about 10 bucks the same
cost is a fucking movie ticket except
there's more effort in getting there
because you have to drive on the highway
for almost an hour
one way and then you have to make sure
you're there early to make sure you have
your seat so I got there like 45 minutes
early guys I'm sorry
I know I get to see movies early
sometimes but the screening process is
far more involved than just going to
theater and paying 10 bucks for a ticket
that's easier I would love to just do
that all the time but I can't because I
like getting reviews out early to you
guys that's the only reason I go to
screenings I would love to just always
go to a movie with the general public
who paid money out of their wallets to
be there and are actually excited to be
there and will more than likely be more
respectful more than likely that's not
always true I've had a lot of terrible
experiences at non screenings as well
but the general vibe of screenings in
Ohio is oh my god this movies free who
cares let's just act like we're at home
what I told you earlier was just the
previews okay if you thought that was
bad imagine sitting there for the first
20 minutes of the conjuring - a very
good horror film that I really liked
with this
I constantly oh my god Oh God
No and everything it just shots of like
the outside of their house Oh God
he cuts to the outside of their backyard
you see a swing going like this Oh God
I'm not exaggerating guys after a while
that can get like death
I can't just just take me now float me
away I'll go up to the clouds anywhere
anywhere of it here that's just the one
thing this person did throughout the
majority of the film whenever anything
actually scary happened like a face
would pop out or somebody would get like
touched on the shoulder
do you have any idea how annoying that
gets after 2 hours and 15 minutes of a
movie
I just know the shit out of myself doing
it for 15 seconds 2 hours and 15 minutes
of oh my god that's my conjuring to
experience and that's just one person
there's an entire group of middle-aged
women towards the right of me I have
more points to make but I have to tell
you these stories so you understand the
points I'm gonna make that's called an
arc it's like an arc you know in a
script so these four middle-aged women
who were over there we're all very
excited I could tell they were just like
a lot of that okay a lot of it so every
time anything frightening happens
uh-uh mm-hmm okay I'm not exaggerating
this is what it's like this is what it's
like to go to a movie screening in
Cleveland for a scary movie it's the
worst the first 20 minutes of the movie
I was just I was done I was like look
this movie seems really good so far and
I'm excited I don't want to have to
experience this and I walked out I
opened the door I was mad I was mad I
opened the door I went in the bathroom
and I counted to ten you know I counted
to ten I was just like this is just
stupid this is crazy there's so many
people talking guys I'm telling you they
were talking so loudly that I couldn't
even hear what the characters in the
movie were saying Dolby Digital 7.1
surround sound could not overpower these
people I counted to ten and I almost
left I was like you know what I'm just
gonna not see this right now I'll see it
at a different screening or I'll go to
the theater Thursday night and I'll pay
I don't care anything and then I said to
myself you know what you got to make
sacrifices you got to make sacrifices I
want to get hourly review of the
conjuring two out I'm gonna sit there
and I'm gonna deal with this I went back
to my seat and the people talked about
the whole movie and you guys have to
understand something this is the
culmination of something that happened
to me at the first conjuring screening
at the first screening I had full-on
audio commentary behind me from you
guessed it three middle-aged women I
turned around I was like ladies if I
wanted audio commentary I would have
bought the blu-ray and they were so
appalled like
oh my god who are these heathens talking
to us like we offended them somehow
after just talking throughout the
entirety of the conjuring every time
anything was going to happen that was
awesome cuz that was a good horror film
oh excuse me
haha I think I pay my money like
everybody else up in here so having it
happen again
at the conjuring two in the exact same
theater mind you was like the arc of
death and I was just sitting there like
you gotta became is shit still happens
when you go to a screening there are so
many announcements always put out your
cell phones don't use your cell phone so
use of recording devices is prohibited
if you're caught with bla bla bla you'll
be escorted out of theater all they have
to do is add one more sentence to that
please do not disrupt the people around
you by talking or being loud thank you
that's all you have to do so to bring
this back home to what I talked about
the beginning this video movie theaters
are afraid of all the at home
entertainment they're afraid that people
are leaving the movie theaters because
their films aren't good enough or
because they don't make enough of
entertaining content or they need better
ideas or better filmmakers are different
revolutionary whatever technology I
don't know people don't go to the
theater as much anymore not because of
those things people don't go to the
theater because other people are
assholes look before I even saw the
conjuring - you can go to my public
Facebook page and see the post I wrote I
wrote before I even went to the
screening I wrote I am terrified of the
conjuring - screening not because of the
film but because of the loud seat
kicking talking imbeciles who will
likely ruin it for me
I wrote that a couple days before I went
to the screening and I was absolutely
right how sad is that there are two
different types of moviegoers guys
there's a people who go to a film
because they're really excited to be
there and they respect the filmmaking
experience and they want to see a great
film they want to be transported away to
another world they want to have that
look on their face of awe as they watch
something amazing and then there's the
people sitting behind you who
continuously snap you out
of that aw with their annoying noise and
cellphone use and what I have to say to
those people is that there is a major
difference between you sitting at home
on your fucking couch and going to a
movie theater you're around other people
who are there because they want to be
not because they want to hear you
shrieking talking laughing pointing
shining lights at the screens opening up
your Facebook because you just have to
know if he commented after he liked your
fucking photo I am so sick and tired of
these idiots and movie theaters and
based on the comments I got on the last
video I made about annoying moviegoers a
lot of you guys are too I don't really
know of a way to combat against this
movie studios don't want to lose money
so they're not going to continuously
force theaters to kick people out just
because they're being loud and obnoxious
because they want money and they also
don't want bad press for their film
because people will then go to Twitter
and say oh you know this movie I got
kicked out oh no
sad face or whatever they don't want
that cuz it's just bad press for their
film I don't know what to do guys I
really don't I think this video which
meant is a form of therapy for myself to
get some of these thoughts out there and
let you guys know how I feel and how
this still goes on over and over again
and also to let you know that if I don't
always have early reviews for movies
it's because I don't enjoy going to
screenings as much anymore I'd much
rather just go to one of the late night
showings on a Thursday night it's a 7
p.m. or 9:30 p.m. and work on my video
and have it up early Friday morning
because now too many people go to the
theater by my house and it's fantastic
and generally the people who do go are
respectful let me end this video with
this and this is the saddest part of the
whole thing at the screening for the
conjuring to the parents that were
sitting next to me brought their very
young kids I'm talking like first grade
level and I was like damn I don't know
if I would have brought my kid it's a
pretty intense movie nevertheless that's
another subject for another time these
children were so much more respectful of
this film than the full grown adult
women
in my aisle and the full grown adult man
sitting behind me these kids were more
respectful of the movie I didn't hear a
peep out of them not one peep
they weren't even shrieking or jumping
or acting scared they were just enjoying
the film these first-grade level kids
were more respectful than the full-grown
adults that's fucking sad I would like
to know for therapy's sake do you guys
also have experiences that you would
like to share please let me know but low
your terrible movie going experiences
and if there's any way that we can
combat against this I mean if they're
going to be loud and obnoxious and ruin
movies for all of us then we have to be
loud and obnoxious to the movie theater
chains and the people who are allowing
this to happen to bring us back to ten
years ago when I was really excited
about going to the movies because we've
lost that guys we've lost respect for
the movie-going experience and we need
to get it back otherwise it'll go away
forever you guys are the best thank you
so much as always for watching thank you
for being a form of catharsis and
therapy I appreciate it guys as always
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes